ici à pontonx la production sera
annuellement 2 9 millions de cassettes
vidéo tout format destiné à 90 % à
l'exportation
le personnel a été entièrement recrutés
dans un rayon de 15 km autour de pontonx
3000 demandes ont été étudiés 200 ont
été retenus 500 d'ici à trois ans
salaire proposé 5% au-dessus de la
moyenne
usine a été construite par le
département des landes
celui-ci la loue à sony qui en sera
propriétaire dans 15 ans son coût 200
millions de francs la politique
industrielle de sony à travers le monde
et d'avoir ses usines là où nous avons
nos marchés c'est-à-dire pour
l'essentiel au japon bien sûr mais aussi
aux états unis et en europe la france
est l'un des grands marchés européens il
était tout à fait naturel que nous ayons
une usine est maintenant 2 en france ces
investissements il promit profite à sony
où il profite aussi à la france par
l'intermédiaire des exportations bien
entendu il profita sioniste et nous ne
le ferions pas nous avons besoin de ces
usines pour alimenter le marché
commercial
mais bien entendu aussi il profite à la
france car une très grande partie de
l'investissement qui a été fait à
bayonne et qui maintenant est fait à
pontonx et financé par des augmentations
de capital en provenance du japon
donc ce sont les japonais eux qui dans
la balance des paiements on voit des
dizaines des centaines de millions de
francs pour financer ses investissements
donc ces investissements étrangers en
termes de balance des paiements sont
très bénéfiques à la france chez sony
comme à bayonne on ne travaille pas à la
japonaise
mais on y pratique cependant une autre
politique du personnel une politique qui
repose sur deux points la responsabilité
individuelle
niveau et la communication est sain de
l'emploi d'ailleurs l'article n'a
communiqué aucun critère déterminant
dans le recrutement du personnel
le tout doit contribuer à l'instauration
d'un état d'esprit différent au sein
d'entreprises mais à la communication
elle s'applique à tous les niveaux il ya
une façon formelle d'abord des réunions
qui sont instituées des réunions
d'information des réunion de tout le
personnel les réunions des cadres des
réunions techniques et en plus d'un
chaque atelier d'un chaque secteur de la
production il ya des réunions de
sections qui sont faites pour permettre
à chacun de participer à la production
et à la gestion des établissements usine
sony de pontonx est aujourd'hui la
deuxième du groupe en france
pontonx à 60 km de bayonne à la fois pas
trop loin pour permettre des relations
étroites entre chaque unité est pas trop
près pour laisser à chacune son
autonomie de fonctionnement en évitant
une seule usine trop importante
sony le toujours produire dans des
entreprises à taille humaine et le cadre
des landes s'y prêtait à merveille